Figuring out whether you're ready for sex,
can be one of the hardest decisions in life.
It doesn't matter whether you're someone wanting to
have sex for the very first time,
or someone who's in a new relationship..
.. where sex hasn't happened yet.
The thought process is pretty much the same.
It's a big step,
and something we should all think
pretty carefully about.
So, how do you know if you're really ready for sex?
First, you need to think about the risks,
associated with sex.
And to be honest, there is a lot of them.
We all know about the health and
pregnancy risks of sex.
And these, are very important.
But, what about the emotional risks?
What do you start to lose?
Will your relationship with that person be changed,
in a way you're not comfortable with?
Sex can make us form a strong, compassionate
connection with someone.
Are you ready for those kinds of emotions?
You might think that having sex is the right thing to do.
But is it really ð™®ð™¤ð™ª, who wants sex?
Or is it the world around you,
pressuring you into doing something
you're not ready for?
Peer pressure is a very real thing,
especially when it comes to sex.
Young people are under enormous pressure
to lose their virginities,
and it kind of becomes a competitive thing.
Alternatively, even if you're not a virgin,
people might still be pressuring you
into having sex with someone new.
In both situations,
we really need to take a step back.
And figure out what ð™¬ð™š want.
And whether we're actually ready for sex.
This one is huge.
Sex can change your relationship in pretty drastic ways.
So it's important to know where you stand.
Is it a serious relationship?
Or are you two more friends than lovers?
You need to make sure that both you,
and your partner, are on the same page.
If one person ends up falling in love,
and the other isn't feeling it,
it can lead to serious emotional
and psychological distress.
And if you two are friends with benefits,
ask yourself if you're willing to
lose that person as a friend.
Because, believe usï¼
it can happen.
Let's take a break from all the deep,
heavy emotional stuff
for some science coolness!
Yes, we're talking about
figuring out when you're ready for sex.
But, what if it's determined by your genes?
That's right.
Researchers at Cambridge University
found that genetics might determine about,
25% of the differences,
between when people lose their virginity.
So what this means, is that losing our virginity
is something we can't rush,
even if we want to.
We have to wait for our bodies to be
biologically prepared,
and for some,
hormones don't start firing until later in life,
simply because of the genetics we were born with.
Sometimes, the best way to come to a decision,
is to look into the past.
What do your past experiences tell you?
Learning from past relationships,
is a natural part of developing,
and maturing as an individual.
And the mistakes we make in the past
can help us improve our future romances.
Did you have sex too early in past relationships?
Maybe you felt like you could've had sex sooner
in your last relationship.
Perhaps you felt like you should've had a discussion
with your partner before taking that next step.
Obviously, this doesn't really apply to virgins.
But if it's still your first time,
you can still learn from the past.
We can all look back on times,
where we rushed things too quickly.
In conclusion,
the most important thing to remember,
is that you should definitely think long and hard about
having sex before going through with it.
If you really ponder everything we just talked about,
we know you'll do the right thing.
No pressure.
If you enjoyed this video,
please like and subscribe to see more content
from Psych2Go.
Thanks for watching!
Now go do something fun.